yeah man it's not like i just wake up
and just decide to cash out
i'm kevin i definitely woke up and
decided to cash out on this i ain't
gonna lie
yo yo it was the kid flip the narrow and
you watching gq on the rocks let's get
it
so let's jump into this my favorite
piece that i have here
is the epic flip dinero sun piece
you know what i'm saying shout out to my
jeweler sean jeweller
if you didn't get it from sean you ain't
shining right but you know what i'm
saying this was pretty much like
just a token of my appreciation to the
game and just showing everyone i'm
really about that when it comes to the
music and the jury
i'm saying so it's a two-sided piece
flip the narrow on the front bust down
the vvs white gold and yellow gold
got the dollar signs in between on the
back
it has an eagle on it the nero gang i'm
saying the reason why i chose the eagle
is because those are one of the birds
that fly the highest i'm saying
so i just feel like a bird represents me
the eagle represents me
and i also got it tatted on my neck so
it's like it's only right you know what
i mean so
yeah this is a very special piece to me
this was a little over 55
but we could lock it another 50 ball
this was something i felt i needed bro
it was mandatory
so let's move on to another one this
piece right here this piece is very
special to
me you know i'm saying this
is a leave me alone piece one on one i'm
saying
i got gifted this from my big brother
johnny shapes because as you know i'm
scientist cinematic music group
and johnny schleich that's like family
you feel me we always speak about just
bettering ourselves with the music and
with the craft i'm saying so
he surprised me with this he caught me
off guard you know what i mean just
because of the progress of the track
leave me alone so and this was a gift
right here i'm saying i don't know the
price on this
i don't even want to know it's priceless
but this is hard though one of my
favorites
for a fact the reaction to seeing leave
me alone go crazy it was it was real bro
you know what i'm saying being in the
streets and just watching the response
from everyone that's in the streets
it was a different type of feeling so it
was surreal
if he was to sum it up in one word you
know what i'm saying
[Music]
i want to jump into the first cuban i
ever cop you know what i'm saying
it's this cuban right here i got this
from sean julia
you know what i'm saying this is
two-tone cuban white gold and yellow
gold
um i always wanted the cuban chain and
i'm saying especially from being from
the hood
you know what i'm saying just seeing all
my homies rock cubans and all the people
who i admired a lot rock humans
it was just something i felt i should
get you know i'm saying this is a trophy
within itself
so this was the first chain i really
really really caught i just bought a
cuban by itself
and this was a little pricey too i ain't
gonna lie i'm saying
a little over 30 but we could just lock
it in that 30.
i copped the longer version of the first
cuban i have two tone
evs stones as well it's just a second
piece just to throw on
it's very expensive very expensive it's
so expensive i don't even like putting
it on sometimes but
[Music]
a lot bro a lot bro a lot
yo just the narrow piece right here oh
my gosh
yo i just want to say yo shout out to
sean that's my jeweler all the way like
i rock with sean all the way till the
wheels follow up insane because
he really shows me love this the dinero
piece
one of one i'm saying i waited a long
time for this you know what i mean
i cop this piece after i dropped my
single how i moved featuring a little
baby
this was pretty much like a milestone
just to show people i accomplished a lot
and i'm saying i reached a different
point in my career and went platinum
so it's just like yeah i just have to
bless myself on time so i cop the dinero
piece
you know man or bust down two-tone too
white golden yellow gold it's expensive
these girls too i got these from sean
man shout out to my guy sean
i hollered at sean i was like yo bro i'm
thinking about getting some permanent
domitique here's like a flip take your
time take your time
i'm like all right whatever you say bro
so pretty much we just kept going back
and forth
until we came to the right solution
i'm saying which was just to pull out
diamond grills eight up top eight or
bottom so it's a sixteen
and yeah that's it i just flooded my
mouth i had to do this i was always a
big fan of mike jones and paul wall when
i was growing up
so as i got older i told myself yo
when i run up that bag i'm gonna
definitely cop me some fronts i had gold
fronts
i had pineapple cut fronts diamond dust
fronts i have everything you name it i
had it
but once i hit these it was just a
different level i couldn't stop it was
it
this one is special too i'm saying this
is lazarus
i actually got this from poppy in the
hood
feel me he gave this to me as a gift you
know what i'm saying just because he
watched me grow up from a kid
i used to always go to him and buy
little earrings and i'm saying just
always get jewelry from him
so this was just like a gift he gave to
him he just threw it in for free one
time it was like i like
take this so i just keep this with me
just to remember where i came from and
i'm saying there's times i rock this
times where i just let it sit but the
times i do rock this that's when i'm
really being humble you know what i'm
saying because this is just a
remembrance of where i came from and
where i'm going
so yeah this is special priscilla's
jewelry store in kenosha
right next to the l train that's my god
i love you popping this all up
so let's bring it to the we the best
cuban you know what i'm saying this
was a gift for my big brother khaled and
i'm saying
um he gave this to me just as a gift
you know i mean he he always told me he
was gonna give me a wee the best chain
but i never really hung myself up on it
until he actually gave it to me
which caught me off guard i ain't gonna
lie you know yeah this was like the
introduction to all the cubans that i
have
it's all the jewelry i have i kid you
not this is like the first
real bust down piece i had it's crazy
i'm saying it means a lot to me if you
see me bring this out
just know some rural about to go down
you're saying this is the real piece
this is the trophy piece right here
facts i got some rings right here i'm
saying all my jewelry i got from sean
and this right here i like to call this
the cake and i'm saying i put this on my
pinky
i'm a haitian dude you know what i'm
saying we from haiti so we like to
rock the pinky rings i'm a caribbean
dude period so i need a pinky ring in my
life
so this was just something mandatory i
felt i should cut you know what i'm
saying
when i when i ran up the bag a little
bit more i just invested in a ring you
know i mean it was like a little 10
piece but it was definitely worth it
one of my favorite rings i owe this one
right here
the cuban this is the bust down cuban
all around and i'm saying not the top no
all around
all around all around bbs knees all
around
i bought this for my um my mother finger
because i'm married to the money
so this is just me being an [ __ ] in
my way whenever i talk i just be like yo
stop talking to me son stop talking to
me you feel me
i just needed this this is something i
woke up and decided to cash out on
i needed this oh so watch
yeah yeah yeah it's all bust down rolly
even the face inside this bus now and
i'm saying this was a gift from my big
brother khaled
anytime i look at this watch i just
heard cali telling me oh go harder
just go hard go hard and i'm saying it's
more to it than just a sean you know i
mean people
buy jewelry just so they can be flashy i
really rock jewelry to remember like
where i came from and what i'm trying to
accomplish for real for real
i'm saying so yeah man this is also a
token of my appreciation to the game
yeah i mean from khaled
shout out to callum man i love you big
bro thank you thank you and we gotta
talk about the spaghetti spaghettis
these are special man
these are some hoopa guests i cop these
from sean too um i'm always losing
earrings
i'm very bad with earrings very very
very bad i'm saying so
i went to shine i was like yo sean i
need something that i'm not gonna lose
and he's like you should get some hoops
he's showing me these i was just going
crazy because these have baguettes
actual diamonds in them these were very
expensive too
you know what i'm saying but i just
cashed out i needed it
i like diamonds but i like jury i'm a
jury fanatic i can't help it
yo yo it's a young boss flip dinero
thank you for checking out my jewelry
collection with gq on the rocks get it
okay